we have a couple different ways to
define factorials and we use the
exclamation mark do you wonder why it's
an exclamation mark because excitement
you know is Victoria oh yeah I'll tell
you why I'll tell you why
there are different kinds of functions
right that's gonna take you sit their
offensive functions and they all grow at
different rates okay so for instance a
function like this as X gets larger and
larger and larger Y also gets larger and
larger larger right but how does it do
it
and what way does it do it it slows down
doesn't it okay never actually stops at
any point anything like that but slows
down okay if you had to put any rank
what what do you think would be the next
in line what would be a faster graph
than this but as it grows faster but not
like like I want the immediate next one
what do you think would be a good thing
to do any takers I reckon this is curved
right I said you know it's growing but
it's slowing down if it didn't slow down
what would it look like something like
this right that's not slowing down we
call this it has a name this is this is
logarithmic this also starts with an L
it's linear alright and it's X or 2x so
it's the same kind of idea right okay
it's constant growth what do you think
would come next now I think we are gonna
get two Exponential's but before then
there's all but missing and there's what
we call polynomial growth okay
now you're like couldn't we put x
squared cubed 4 5 6 and so on all the
way there I suppose you could but really
they're all the same kind of growth they
all exhibit much the same kind of
behavior right and when you do the
derivatives you can see it's borne out
by that Exponential's come in next
the Exponential's are fast they're
insanely fast it's hard to illustrate
how fast they are okay
and that's why exponential growth in
wherever we encounter it just it's you
know it's crazy we use it as a language
to say something's gone really fast
oh it's growing exponentially right
there's something faster than
Exponential's
it's the factorial function next to the
factorial function the exponential
function looks like a snail right
there's no way to put them next to each
other right so they put an exclamation
mark that's what they mean okay now if
you had to give a definition of the
factorial function it equals what is it
equal what's on the other side of the
equal sign what are you gonna say you
know you start with in and then you
multiply by something don't you
you want to apply by the previous number
and then you multiply by the number
before that and you keep on multiplying
until you're gonna get down to one an
inch stop okay
now there's a variety of reasons why
this is an all right definition to start
with but not good enough okay
um for starters you know when you think
about okay what might a number be I
could put in example 5 factorial I think
it's the definition just fine okay but
then some numbers quite clearly make it
break right
like if the number isn't isn't what's
that all right if the number is zero
which is kind of an important number
what's that we've discussed this before
actually so there's a lot of reasons why
this is a voce definition but we want a
better one okay so a better one would be
where's my a better definition than this
would be a recursive definition not
recursion somebody who you are familiar
with this idea
a recursive definition define something
in terms of itself and you think that's
a bad thing
isn't it well not if you do it right
I'll show you what I mean okay I can say
in factorial what is that okay let's
just look at the beginning here okay you
think in the beginning we know it has to
start with whatever that number is okay
now what do you multiply after that well
I'm going to write it recursively I'm
gonna write it in terms of factorials n
factorial is n times some other number
what is the other number and the answer
is it's n minus 1 factorial okay that's
what it is okay so this recursive
definition is much more helpful to us
right and then you get down to you know
just like in normal recursion you have
to go down and go down you climb down
the ladder and eventually you get to the
bottom which is zero factorial equals
one okay so this is a better definition
okay not only does it um you know deal
with all these guys in between okay but
it helps you work with things it's in
five factorial I've chosen small numbers
so doesn't freaky brain out okay I know
you can do this without any
sophisticated techniques okay my point
is that you can use this recursive
definition to work with that a lot more
easily
okay in order to cancel this out all I
want is a common factor that's how we
cancel things out right now I can find a
common factor by using this definition
right okay five factorial by the
definition what's it equal to its M
times n minus 1 factorial cool now
that's that's good but we're still there
right we have to go again we have to go
down the ladder one more step so I'm
gonna do that for that row by definition
is 4 by 3 factorial
and now I had the factor I was after but
of course you get your answer 20 okay
now this was easy because five and three
are small numbers okay
but when you have ends and ahhs and
other things you don't actually know
what they are right this technique right
some people called the textbook likes to
clot I'm rolling a factorial I guess
it's kind of like you know this this is
kind of like a theme all knotted up on
itself right and this is having it
unrolled just a little bit right and now
it's like oh look see that pot that's
that's the end I can see that and I can
deal with it separately right this here
you know it's it's it's rolled up enough
so that the rolled off bits are the same
but three factorials okay and you look
what's left over is the five and the
four that's how much had to take out and
then I've got my color back okay so this
seems simple right